elle sillonne les routes de normandie
depuis quatre ans de haras en écurie
mode de fortescue inspectent entretien
soigne les bouches des chevaux qui s'ils
le pouvaient s'en passait bien je pense
qu'il va être très simple gentil car les
chevaux n'ont pas toujours eu besoin de
soins dentaires du temps où ils broutent
elle est verte prairie la corrosivité de
l'herbe suffisait à limay lors dents qui
poussent en permanence mais la
domestication à modifier leurs habitudes
alimentaires et a donc créé le besoin du
fait que nos choix sont beaucoup en boxe
à manger des choses qui sont quand même
moins abrasives que l'herbe mais on a
besoin de faire venir le dentiste
régulièrement corps mou nivelle les
dents de lui tant elle supprime toutes
les sûr dans les pointes des mailles qui
pourrait laisser la bouche du cheval via
l'action du mort une intervention qui se
fait généralement une fois par an sauf
pour les grands cavaliers qui y
recourent plus niveau des cavaliers
peuvent avoir parfois des réactions
brutales ou incompréhensibles du cheval
au contact de leurs mains et donc ils
nous appellent pour essayer de d'aplanir
de résoudre un petit peu cette cette
relation difficile entre les deux il est
bien loin le temps où les
maréchaux-ferrants face et en coup de
lime sur les dents à prévoir ferrer un
cheval la profession de technicien
dentaire et qu'un s'est structuré et été
officiellement reconnu il ya trois ans
aujourd'hui les instruments ont beaucoup
évolué ils permettent de faire des soins
de façon très facilité et sans avoir eu
à utiliser une débauche d'énergie
gigantesque et en cas de problème lors
d'une extraction dedans par exemple les
dentistes peuvent solliciter l'aide des
vétérinaires pour une anesthésie car
pour eux comme pour nous le passage chez
le dentiste est un moment redouté mais ô
combien nécessaire